good morning thanks for getting up early
to be here with us even despite the fact
that some of our thunder might have been
stolen by the three or four
presentations before this that demoed
the navigation editor luckily we have
time to go into a little bit more detail
than any of the previous presentations
so there's a lot of good material here
and I'm Lucas product manager for
architecture components and with me I
have Ian and Sergey who built the
navigation component and navigation if
you think about it is a problem that
pretty much every app on Android has to
solve but until now we haven't really
given you anything to do that with other
than start activity which for various
reasons is not the best way to go about
that so if you think about yeah our job
of making Android development easier
navigation was a common problem with no
real solution and that means that there
are a lot of things that you have to
solve on your own and those range from
how to commit fragment transactions
hopefully without throwing an exception
how to test that navigation is happening
correctly and that the right things are
happening when navigation occurs how to
map deep links to various places in your
app and how to keep that deep those deep
link schemes up-to-date as your app
navigational structure changes passing
arguments from place to place again we
don't give you a type safe way to do
that today how to make sure that up and
back
take users to the right places
particularly in sort of more difficult
situations like someone deep linking
deep into your apps navigation hierarchy
and so what this means is by the time
you've finished solving these problems
you typically gone one of two directions
you've either written 60% of a
navigation framework
or you've got a lot of error-prone
boilerplate everywhere navigation needs
to happen in your app so you've got a
bunch of parallel lines of code solving
these various problems and the whole
structure is fairly brittle and that's
why we're oh sorry and individually
these problems are pretty tractable but
if you look at kind of a real-world
example you can see that they can get
pretty hairy so say that I have an item
screen in my app and it's accessible via
deep link so far so good but if someone
had navigated to this screen via opening
the app from the home screen they would
have a couple other screens on the back
stack and so hitting it up we want them
to take that not out of the app from the
item screen we want them to go to the
category screen and then the home screen
and that means that if someone deep
links into the app we need to synthesize
these screens and add them to the up
stack before showing the item screen and
talking to a third-party developer he
told me it's when you're in the middle
of writing the code to do this to
synthesize these screens and add them to
the up and back stack but only on a deep
link that's when you start to feel like
maybe you're solving a failure of the
framework so it's just help solve
problems like that that we're launching
navigation and what we're giving you is
a visual tool that lets you edit the
navigation graph of your app which is
represented in XML and that lets you
define a set of available navigation
actions arguments you can pass from
place to place things like visual
transitions and then a single navigate
call activates all that at runtime and
so last but not least that means one
thing you never have to worry about
again is touching a fragment transaction
with your bare hands
[Applause]
so what the navigation graph is
essentially just a set of what are the
possible destinations people can reach
in my app and those usually correspond
to screens but not always so you can
have the navigation control or just
changing the contents of a smaller part
of the screen but it's a set of
navigation destinations and the actions
that link them and the actions really
represent how you can get from place to
place so to actually navigate from point
A to point B in an app you're just gonna
call the correct navigation action at
runtime so let's take a look at what
this looks like and let's switch over to
the demo okay so what we see here is a
set of navigation destinations and these
are fragment destinations although other
options are possible and the lines
connecting them with the arrowheads are
our actions and those actions actually
generate methods that you can call at
runtime
this whole thing is backed by XML as you
all know and love and the XML and the
navigation editor have the same set of
capabilities so you can use either one
we're gonna add a screen here and what
you're seeing is a set of available
activities and fragments in my app ok so
we just added an option for them to
actually answer this question
successfully and win the game so now
we're gonna add an action to navigate to
that screen
great and so that navigation action has
a bunch of options that you can set
obviously we're going to talk about
those a little bit more for now we're
gonna do one thing so we're gonna say if
they've gotten to this congratulations
screen that means the game is over so
hitting back shouldn't take them back
into a game that no longer exists so
what that means is we want to on that
action say let's pop to the match screen
and that means I'm going to pop off
everything on the back stack in between
this destination and the match screen so
when the user gets to the
congratulations screen when they hit
back they're just going to go straight
to the match screen so a lot of other
options I can set but let's talk about
that for now let's go back and look at
the congratulations screen again
one other thing to mention that the the
key thing that is set here is the
fragment class and that's what's
actually instantiated at runtime and we
see layout previews here because the
layout the Navigation editor knows what
layout is associated with that
navigation graph and because it knows
what layout is associated with that
navigation graph I can double click on
that fragment destination to get here
into the layout editor great and
everything that I've just done here
adding this new destination to the
navigation graph an action changing what
that pop behavior of that action is all
this stuff I can also do
programmatically at runtime so
navigation editor XML or programmatic
all work just fine great
and now I'm gonna hand this off to get
to walk you through this in more detail
so the first question that might come to
mind is wow this is a totally new way of
kind of structuring the UI every rap and
kind of brings up this question
immediately like okay so what what is my
activity actually meant to do right so
every kind of app has a very different
starting point from where you guys are
right now or maybe as of two days ago on
how you've kind of structured the UI of
your app some may be very activity heavy
very fragment heavy very much in a
different system all those are certainly
very valid places to be but we're moving
towards a model where the activity is
more just an entry point into your app
rather than the activity being the owner
of the content of your app it's actually
just what's going to store kind of that
global state so the global navigation so
if you have bottom navigation drawers
you're still using an action bar those
are the kind of things that activities
manage but it delegates to what we call
a nav host for content so our nice super
simple activity here we have an action
bar on the top the bottom nav on the
bottom and this big white box in the
middle that's our nav host so in the
world of navigation when you navigate
between different destinations in your
app we're actually doing is just
replacing everything inside that box
right so you have kind of that global
navigation outside of that and we have
hooks that you can hook that up to stay
in sync with the actual nav host so what
does a super simple version of this look
like well if you're using fragments for
destinations you want to use our nav
host fragment so here we just have a
activity layout that is literally just
our one fragment so you do this by
including the navigation fragment
dependency as you might expect if you're
using a totally different kind of
destination it would probably also have
a different kind of nav host that you
add here whether it's a custom view or
whatever other item that they need but
for a nav host fragment we've kind of
set up a few convenience methods the
ability to set what navigation graph
you're using in XML so you don't need to
do anything programmatically to set it
up it'll just go to the start
destination of your graph by default and
then for fragments we can actually hook
this up to the system back button so we
offer a method to do exactly that
so you don't have to override on back
pressed specifically for navigation will
kind of hook up all that stuff using the
magic of fragments through this default
nav host option so that means that our
activity actually gets to be two lines
of code it would be two lines but it
doesn't fit horizontally on a slide but
all we need to do is just inflate our
layouts that content view and then hook
up the UP button now normally this is a
large operation but because you've told
us about the structure of your graph
what we can do is in this case we're
using a Kotlin extension method on
activity it'll just be a static method
for Java users that allows us to find
the navigation controller by passing in
the ID in this case the ID of our nav
host fragment and that just gives us
access to navigate up and navigate up is
going to do the right thing
based on your navigation graph you don't
need to actually do a lot of extra work
here by giving us your graph we are able
to do this for you but for most EPS
just having a single thing is not
actually what you have maybe you have
something a little bit more so we've
kind of set up a second dependency
navigation UI which is really just a set
of static methods that connect your
navigation component with some of the
material design components some of the
things like bottom nav and things like
that that are very much in that kind of
global navigation space but of course it
it's 2018 so we have KTX
one that changes those static methods
into extension methods on the classes
that they operate on so this is really
easy for Kotlin users to kind of
integrate it into your app and have
navigation feel like it's just something
that exists in all of the components
that are out there so what does this
look like if we again kind of make our
navigation or our activity a little bit
more complicated without a toolbar on
the top and we'll add a bottle
navigation view and in this case we
still have the same kind of app menu
that you had before on a bottom
navigation view but what we do to kind
of hook those things up it takes two
parts one your menu here is actually
going to be using the same IDs that
you've had on each destination so each
destination has a unique ID and we can
actually use those same IDs on your menu
items so that kind of builds this
implicit link of oh well if you click
the home menu item you're going to go to
the home destination of your app so in
code we're just going to set up our
action bar using our toolbar and then we
can do the same find nav controller to
get our access to the nav controller
object and then we just have a column
extension for activity that allows you
to say set up action bar with nav
controller and this does Oh quite a bit
of magic but what it's doing is it's
actually going to be receiving events on
when you've navigated in your nav
controls and using the labels that
you've set up in your navigation graph
to update the title of your action bar
and we also have another helper method
if you're using a drawer layout to
automatically change it from a hamburger
button into a back arrow based on what
destination you're on so really kind of
just those helpful patterns to make sure
that those things stay in sync similarly
for the bottom nav it it's just you just
call set up you call set up with nav
controller and redo the two-way syncing
here so as you click on things in the
now if it'll change the graph and do the
correct transition based on the material
guidelines as well as as you navigate
between your app if you have separate
buttons it'll actually update the
selected item in the bottom navigation
so this gives us a lot of power but not
everyone is just using pre-built
components that another team has
provided you have your own custom UI
right so at that point we really need to
go deeper into what mouse controller
actually gives you and for the super
simple case you have a button you want
it to go somewhere we have a convenience
method create navigate onclicklistener
you give it the ID of where you want to
go
what destination what action you want to
trigger and we'll do all the work for
you now
this is perhaps a little bit too magical
so you can't unroll it just a little bit
in this case we're using another
extension method on view so from any
view that's been created by nav
controller you can actually get a
reference to your nav controller just by
calling fine nav controller as you might
expect and use that nav controller to
call navigate and just navigate to an ID
of a destination or an action in your
graph nut that's it like under the
covers this navigate is actually doing a
lot of work so the nav controller is
talking to what we call a navigator and
so for fragments we were talking to a
fragment navigator that we provide and
that navigator knows everything about oh
you called navigate I know what fragment
you're going to because you gave us your
class name and it's going to build all
of the fragment transactions for you
it's going to call add to back stack
it's going to do all the things you told
us to do by putting that information in
your navigation graph so if you had pop
up too it's going to do all that sort of
stuff
transitions all of that is in this one
line of code and all of it can be
determined either programmatically we
can add additional options to this
method or
something that you determine ahead of
time as part of your navigation graph
but for a lot of these kind of places
it's not actually just a navigate right
you have some information to pass to the
next source so for this you need to pass
a bundle of information so here we're
passing a string and an int and we're
using our nice helpful bundle of from
Android KTX
and it works it's fine this is really
useful for a lot of things but at the
same point it's not very safe if you do
a Mis type here like what are you gonna
do so we really want to make this a lot
easier Sergei is gonna talk about what
we did here yeah we built something
called save ours Gradle plugin and it
will help you a little bit but first of
all let's see what they're trying to
resolve and let's go back to our sample
our fragment we helped fragment where we
try to navigate actually it requires us
to pass a screen name argument and
optionally you can pass category which
has integer type and let's go back to
the calling side well in our slice we
made everything correctly we passed
screen and it has proper type we passed
category test proper type as well but
actually junk refactorings or some other
medications you can forget the best
screen name it's a result in run time
exception and don't get me wrong it's
super easy to fix but it feels annoying
it feels like what am i JavaScript
developer why this is this compile time
check like I don't know
so yeah you decided okay now we have
this navigation graph let's put all
about navigation there including clear
arguments that of your destinations so
let's see how it looks like an XML and
it's super simple we just specify your
argument name it's type
additionally can specify default value
it means that your argument is optional
and this allows us to build tooling that
once you have an action that leads to
this fragment or our action or activity
we can check and make you the best
proper arguments so look let's take a
look how it looks likely for our Gradle
plugin now syndicate we use this special
object which instead of passing ID and a
bundle of course internally the subject
incorporates the same ID and same
arguments but to get that object we use
home fragment Direction class it's
generated for you you know it's just a
fragment name plus suffix directions and
this has static methods for every action
defined for this destination and those
static methods make you pass required
arguments so in our case with it makes
us the best home argument there and yeah
optionally can but later set up your
other additional arguments and
everything is type safe and receiving
side after that is super simple we have
this bodger
we generate for you its arcs class so
for our case it's called fragment arcs
and you just have all your arguments
that you defined in a type safe manner
and from this relatively small life
improvement we go to the bigger one
which is deep links yes so deep links
are traditionally something that Android
has supported for the longest time so
you can add intent filters to activities
and you know take over a web URL as well
as like deep linking is super useful for
notifications and things like that
to link back into your app but this gets
a lot more complicated as you get a more
complicated app like how you structure
these things and how you say like
alright I need to build a notification
what is all of the code
needed to actually get into the correct
place in my app and past the right kind
of information here so for navigation
who really made deep linking kind of a
first-class citizen in our structure so
there's really two kinds of deep links
the explicit kind so these are things
like for notifications app shortcuts app
widgets and the new actions and slices
things that are things that you create
and are usually pending intent based
these are all things that you're passing
to another app or to the system to say I
want to go to this specific place in my
app the implicit side of things are more
around the web URLs and custom scheme
URLs so these would be other apps
triggering your app to launch and we
handle both of these for navigation for
explicit deep links we have a specific
class called Navdeep link builder and
its sole goal in life is to deep link to
a specific destination in your
navigation graph by its ID but it's
going to do all of that work like it's
easy to say but it's a little bit harder
to actually make sure that all works in
the system but if we create a nav deep
link builder you create a context you
give it your graph your destination any
arguments you have and then you can just
call create pending intent and we're
doing all the work here to create the
right synthetic back stack both within
your graph and if you're using multiple
activities your parent activities as
well and we're gonna pass that along and
create the correct intent that gives you
to the right place when you trigger this
intent and then you just pass it through
to your notification you don't actually
need to do more than this to get all the
correct behavior for implicit deep links
these are again kind of links to web
URLs right so in this case instead of it
being something that you create
programmatically it's information you
include in your navigation graph so here
we're adding a deep
link element just like we added the app
arguments and actions to our graph these
are just a deep link and of course do
all of this in the visual editor as part
of the properties for a destination and
it's really just as simple as an app :
URI and you pass in a URI now this is a
static URI which is boring and dumb and
you know there's only so many apps that
have just one URI they do so we of
course support some wildcards so if you
want to do a dot star for a wild card
totally supported if you want to fill in
the arguments for your destination you
can actually use curly braces and will
parse the URL for you and extract those
values and give them to you for your
arts so again kind of in that same type
safe args now you can get those directly
from your URL and not have to reparse
things like you already know what this
is supposed to be similarly you can kind
of combine the two if you want to make
more complicated patterns totally can we
also have support for auto verify if
you're using app links to skip that
disambiguation screen we wanted to make
sure that you could do the same kind of
thing if you're using navigation as well
and you'll note here that we left off
the HTTP HTTPS so what we're doing here
is actually doing both we're saying HTTP
HTTPS now I assume your servers are all
HTTPS but you can't really control the
URLs that other apps are including to
your app maybe they accidentally took
baths off of your URL we still want to
support both of those so we use this
just as a convenience method instead of
having two lines step one and of course
it also works with custom schemes so if
you have your own scheme that you set up
specifically for your app you can also
attach those two deep links now the best
part is we've kind of worked across the
tool space so besides just the
navigation editor
we've also worked with the manifest
merger team so you can add just a single
nav graph element to an activity in your
manifest pointing to your graph and all
of the deep links in that graph will
then get expanded out to be the correct
intent filter we will build all those
for you and if you go to the manifest
merger view in Android studio you
actually see the exact line from your
navigation file that generated not
intent filter so this means that we now
have a single source of truth in your
navigation graph that you know this is
not gonna get out of sync with what
you've expect it's not gonna get out of
sync as you change argument names in
your XML file all of this is kind of one
central place to do things and we think
this is a lot easier for basically all
of the implicit deep link kind of cases
of course we do do things where this is
all action view URLs as they would be
for web URLs so you can see it's added
directly to the line and if you have
multiple of them it'll actually tell you
exactly what line if you have multiple
graphs associated with different
activities those will all work just fine
so one of the other subjects that is
really important to all of architecture
components is testing and testing of
navigation is very hard and this is
something that we're going to continue
to look at over the alpha period and we
really want all of your feedback as well
but I wanted to kind of discuss what we
think testing in a navigation world
should look like so a lot of it is if
all of the links between your
destinations are through navigation then
it's a lot easier to test a destination
in isolation right you can test each
destination by itself and then test just
the outgoing edges or just
the incoming arguments and not have to
deal with oh did it actually do the
right fragment transaction because we
can test that just at the navigation
controller level so this is something
that we are going to spend a lot more
time on and in the fragment talk
yesterday we actually talked about
really trying to make fragments
themselves much more testable in
isolation so it's kind of a package deal
where we are trying to build testing
into navigationcontroller but then also
trying to build testable destinations as
well so you might be interested to do
something right now so figure out an
espresso test and you want to test oh
when I get to something does it go to
the right place well we actually have a
add-on navigator navigated listener so
you can actually hook it up to the nav
controllers navigator and get a callback
of oh did you go to the right place when
I click this button so this is one
method that we found pretty successful
in kind of testing things completely
black box outside of things obviously if
you want to inject a nav controller or
use any other method those are also
perfectly valid ways of kind of setting
things up so what can you play with
today and what can you play with you had
two days must have looked at it right so
it is an alpha right now one point zero
zero alpha zero one we're giving
ourselves a long runway of bug fixes and
improvements here and it really comes
down to two main artifact the navigation
fragment which includes the navigation
runtime dependency as a transitive
dependency and also the nav host
fragment and the fragment navigator that
you need to use fragment destinations as
well as the navigation UI dependency
which has those static methods and for
every one of the dependencies for
navigation we have a dash KTX version of
them if you
using Colin so we really tried to make
Colin a first-class citizen in the
navigation world especially for some of
the things like if you are doing
programmatic graph construction like say
you're reading your whole navigation
graph from a server we have a Colin DSL
as part of our column extensions to make
that a lot easier if you're using Colin
so there is more to do and I'll have
Lukas talk about kind of where we're
going yeah OneNote you are gonna need
Android studio 3.2 preview canary 14 to
use this and please do download it and
try it out there's a lot of great stuff
there so this is obviously going to
become a really core part of not just
architecture components but jetpack
overall so with jetpack we're gonna take
the same approach we took with
architecture components I can sort of a
blank sheet of paper what do we want the
Android developer experience to be and
apply that much more broadly and
navigation will be eventually part of
the default experience so when we get to
stable then you know creating a new
project in Android studio is going to by
default start you up in the navigator
and should be a pretty great world and
jetpack is available for you to try
right now it's right now it's sort of
got a much nicer introduction to what
all the key pieces of Android
development are so it's a much easier on
ramp and we're looking forward to
expanding this story over ton there are
more talks for you to go to a lot more
detail on Android KTX and paging
paging in particular is a really cool
deep library that does a lot for you by
tying together different pieces of
architectural components in jetpack so I
encourage you if you ever have a
ListView with more stuff than you can
hold and memory at any given time you
really want to go to this paging Talk
and we want your feedback we want your
feedback on this session first of all
but more importantly we want your
feedback on the navigation component the
reason that we're launching to alpha is
not because we think that this is sort
of you know really untested and untried
we've actually done a lot of pre-release
testing of this but we were launching it
to alpha because we want to get a lot of
feedback from the community on it before
we lock down the API and switch over to
beta so this is a great time for you to
try it out
tell us what works for you tell us what
doesn't and you know either communicate
with us directly or on our public issue
tracker we would love to hear from you
your feedback has been really critical
in every point of this journey and
making sure that we're attacking the
right problems with the right solutions
so please do try it out and tell us what
you think and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you